right and we all laugh with masa going
on but this man flashpoint is back I am
exciting lots and lots to talk about how
are you doing sir
I'm doing good overall not too shabby
kind of an interesting morning for both
of us but got to squeeze this thing in
so it's good
apparently Bungie is just dropping some
new stuff all the time so more coming
our way which is nice
exactly Conte ain't me what's going
hunting update you getting rolled Matt
but we got a lot to talk about
you know I didn't know I thought this
was actually gonna be a quiet week in
the mail every time but more than talk
about just means they keep it going
exam well yeah development roadmap we'll
just kind of jump right in was the big
dropped on Wednesday so on Twitter deej
was just like development roadmap update
question mark and everybody's like yeah
yeah so that was a pretty easy yes and
that B had said we got a little bit of
news so well we already know that May
29th we're gonna have update one point
two point one which I don't think anyone
expected anything that soon three weeks
well so apparently they figure out
something with faction rally
improvements they've got a couple you
know week and a half to figure out what
that's gonna be they'll probably drop
that info next week after iron banner
goes this week mm-hm but faction rallies
is coming back do you think I have
enough time to make it something plague
yeah we were hoping for some big changes
this seems a little fast I was actually
figuring this might be summer or fall
like to do bigger changes this is quick
this is definitely a quick turnaround
there's no doubt about it it's gonna be
interesting to see how they handle um
you know obviously they want to make a
more substantial impact and you know I
want to see how what stuff they can't
implement with that you know I'm shout
out to unknown he's got a video of
somebody believed not the ornaments with
some of the weapons in it so he didn't
seem inspired by the weapons but I
definitely want to see how they really
approach it actually um did you did you
find out about the like some factions
have Mackey
exotics or master or catalysts and
things exclusive to certain factions oh
I did not see that yes
so what shout out to unknown man I don't
player he's got a really good video out
right now and um yeah apparently I
believe like I know one of them for a
fact he's making me as a warlock
question during I think I believe its
new monarchy the warlock helmet high of
another world it has a unique ornament
for my understanding chest a pledge to a
future war cult that we so they look
like they're trying to add specific arm
emotes and ornaments and actually exotic
catalysts as well I believe our catalyst
is interesting that all graviton Lance I
believe is uh I think it don't quote me
see that it's not new market either the
catalyst for graviton is gonna be I
believe it's a dead orbit really yeah
man no one's got a great video out right
now and it talks about that I'm like
okay so they're definitely trying to
make those decisions tougher as to which
faction you actually choose yeah
seriously well unfortunately graviton
will win cuz I mean that's the gun
everybody wants it's killing it one with
big what else you gonna do yeah well be
the problem is this is this is a fashion
show has shown that if those Shady's is
right I was like right now there's some
function to go for function if good
enough might take over faction because
nothing else have mattered except
fashion before they exist some of the
things are starting to matter random
aside though I didn't want to ask you
real quick sure simply you know I mean
there's other content out there and
stuff like that but if you guys want
actually here sometime if you just want
to hear the devs actually open up a
little bit yeah the DCP podcasts they
just had some time and they just the
devs actually got to talk it was nice
the podcast guys mostly listened and
again it's your choice if you want to
hear other people or not but honestly
just to hear the devs Josh Hamrick and
John wise news ki just go at it for a
while open up get on the road I mean
they
say some things you're probably going I
don't know if you supposed to like
totally say a couple things they're not
like big you know crazy things but it
was just nice to hear those guys talk
let to know let us know where they were
coming from yep
just all the different pieces for I mean
they did want it to be more of a fashion
show or things where we call and then
they figured out things didn't work you
can actually see some of their thought
process so if you're wondering it's a
lengthy one but I think it was number 84
so look for the one with Hamrick and it
will let you guys get a little bit of
behind the scenes because it was nice
just to listen to two devs that have
been working their tail off they've been
through halo days and everything else
and it gives you an idea of what their
process they were thinking of what they
wanted to do for you know getting people
on the same playing field let people you
know everybody complained about traz ma
transmog and stuff before so now the
armour doesn't matter but you can look
how you want to but now they've learned
the values of armour and stats and stuff
do still matter so they've tried to
appease both sides so it's just a nice
piece if you guys want to jump in and
again if you ever want some more info on
a little listening time after our couple
hours kills your ears we are happy to
you know let you guys hear the devil's
bunchy podcast don't come out that often
so totally get those guys on one for a
while it's a good one to listen to yeah
absolutely man I was a DCP
it was a fantastic episode you
definitely put me onto it and he was
like you said it's great to hit a
thought process even the you know just
the reason they come to certain
conclusions and just to hear the history
from where they start especially with
new ski when he was talking about the
Bungie days and stuff like that and even
his history I think he was like a game
like any sound like that so it's always
your Nintendo that's right that was cool
yeah man it's very very cool man oh yeah
definitely shout out to those guys check
that out and you can actually hear these
guys are interacting with the community
man yeah so it was just a good long
in-depth one of those two it's nice to
see a long-form discussion with people
you want to get a little more out of as
opposed to their very curated things
sometimes it was nice to get a little
little freedom out of them but yeah so
one point two point one you guys know we
got warmind all the good stuff is there
we'll have our thoughts on a couple
pieces as we go through for what is to
come in the future first we said faction
early improvements is there anything I
mean
catalyst is
kind of crazy I know pulling it back
here but and that'll make you think yeah
dude I'm telling you right now like I
like that kind of stuff because at the
end of the day like again you know it's
gonna force my hand I'm a new monarchy
guy like that's where I've been
investing - and you're talking about a
warlock specific exotic you know
ornament or one you know once a faction
another opposite faction you're talking
about a a very wanted catalyst now
County the rain stats that the base
that's really jump up you know graviton
we know it's all the rage right now it's
like the one that shout out it's the
meta straight-up it's meta insane
yeah so why are you talking about making
that even more that'll be interesting so
we'll probably get next week some stuff
to talk about I'm sure with regards to
that and sorry guys if in the future
weeks we have some weird timings I'm
gonna take the blame on that one Cagney
knows got us get with solid schedule
mines off a little bit so I can't let
you take all the blame I know you guys
still actually next weekend myself to is
gonna be look crazy okay so you know
John it will be touch and go how weeks
yeah so we might do solos one side or
the other but we'll definitely try and
keep you guys abreast of all the new
info so absolutely but as you guys saw
in the thumbnail if you did click on
this when you got this far at least the
next thing is called crucible labs and
literally the first thing Derek Carol is
like alright what is crucible labs
because everybody know with regards to
crucible labs actually you want to jump
in lets you steal this one for a bit
yeah man he just said basically you know
people's like hey what is it he said
it's gonna be a new feature intended at
you you are peek behind the scenes a lot
of voice in the creative process
crucible labs would give every player
that's need to access to experimental
EVP content and then we'll have a chance
to solicit your feedback to guide final
iteration so you're gonna hear more
about it for launch they just wanna give
us a preview this is extremely dope I am
very proud of them with this um I didn't
expect this I'll be I'll be really I did
not expect anything like this I know
this has been one from the community the
PvP community big shot of all our plays
in
guys you know um they didn't want stuff
like this for a while because we all
felt like you know you're the private
matches is cool but um I think what this
what this represents is part of our
outcry as to why they're so slow to
update the meta yeah so now if you have
this specific environment this crucible
lab where we can if they want to buff
you know Scout rifles when we cook
grenade launchers let's start there
yeah let's not you know go until those
feel good and then we'll move to
something exactly and just to test it
and then the computer can give that
real-time feedback like hey I'm diggin
the place that you got them right now my
fighting lion actually feels like it's
doing something my played a game grenade
launcher feel like you know killed by
that actually a couple times then we
came back why in the fight lion yeah I
felt really but no like legit he had
like two seconds just like tagged her in
a corner I was like what is happening it
was like five nine I was like are you
serious right now so I was like it was a
weird match there's only one recently
but somebody was having a little fun
with it I guess somebody figured out I
use it I mean your energy slot it has
some potency just because it's sitting
there but oh yeah
it's it they always feel weak in PvE and
PvP it may feel a little bit better if
you got like a to tap or however that I
don't even know the perk on that thing
haven't looked at it and so long but in
general like I know what PvP they could
be reasonable I've been killed by a few
here there if people are accurate but
PvE they're awful awful awful I mean I
don't try to say that word very often
but you feel so weak when you use those
compared to basically anything else like
mm-hmm
I don't know so they need some help
across the board but being able to test
weapons in here does sound really good I
mean even if it's just another playlist
like they put another knob some like
another button somewhere and you're like
hey instead of jumping into doubles go
down below this hey this is our crucible
labs maybe it's not quite as obvious but
if you know it's there they'll say okay
for this week we're gonna go throw this
out there and see what happens we're
making at least feel stuff out I like
the fact that they're giving the public
now do they want the public to spoil
stories unlike a complete you know test
Rome like World of Warcraft where you
test out the raid no cuz that does kind
of take away from things but at least
you can get gunplay feeling testing
exotics get ideas out there that'll be
good so a lot of it man that that is
fantastic I didn't expect this welcome
addition you know it's a little
weirdness so not the other thing like
twenty nine like two weeks less than
that's not didn't expect this now and
the third one one we have all been
waiting on and we'll wait it now this is
part one so they're not coming yet but
exotic armor sandbox changes dude this
is like my birthday this is like mines
in July so world documenting dude it's
like you know how I feel about exotic
Alma I've been so even d1 like you know
just really you know touch these things
up man I mean I got a on fluxes doing
nothing I got you know so much cool
looking gear that the functionality is
not good and we know that they tend to
always gravitate towards the weapons
being tweaked and buffed and nerfed but
nothing core exotic armor and yeah man I
got a ton of stuff in my fault that I'm
like I'm looking at you Luna faction
boots you know I'm looking at you know
you Starfire protocol I mean so you got
like lying a rampart you've got nude
marchers sprint speed little just random
stuff as you said I mean okay so Orpheus
rigged that one probably won't get
touched it so P as it is but yeah
there's so many of them I mean even just
Sun breakers are still the a on the
whole thing yet whole group of stuff is
not great not great at all even that new
one it that one that comes at the end of
the war mind and a brave strike it's
kind of like this weird-looking helmet
it's for all three classes it kind of
has that same a off like so with the
other Mary charge or saris brow or
whatever yeah it's like they've got
these cool concepts
but it's like they've got to really it's
like what I'm very hopeful because let's
be real based on what they did for
exotic weapons they deserve a clap like
they transform graviton Lance which was
worst delivered into a fully functional
PvE weapon with Splash Damage and one of
the most dominant crucible weapons right
now I think is the laser beam has no
bullet drop off I can two two three tap
people it's disgusting right so just to
see them do these kind of things with
that sky burners all these great weapons
look at you know vigilance
you know exotics becoming that's how
they're getting the time to kill down by
by making exotics exotic and and now you
talk about Alma I'm excited man because
I really feel they're getting it now
with sniewski Hamrick knows I think
they're putting it together the sandbox
guys and knowing what we want so now it
makes my quizzes the first time I'm
playing destiny so I'm going on from
tangent sorry no no he's all exactly now
I'm excited um this is the first time in
destiny to where I sat then I looked
through my exacts on my damn I don't
want to take graviton off right now but
damn my crimson is like it was a tough
decision now I had that feeling like I
had a wealth of these arms what to use
for what situation cuz each of them gave
me great functionality they were feeling
truly exotic the first time I felt that
in destiny too you know I mean in a
while wait yeah absolutely man
I mean I I'm really happy about it so to
see what they've done with weapons I'm
super excited about what they can do the
armor I can't wait I'm super excited for
this change so me too was one caveat oh
oh that bad and no it's what we've
talked about before armor still needs to
have more stuff to it and that stuff I
think we've got to wait for the fall but
if they can take the exotics and point
them in the right direction like many
other things they've been doing I'm
happy to see where they take them so we
give me one exotic that you real
want to see something special with
exactly just cuz it looks so terrible
I would love to for people to have to
wear this thing for it to be so good the
eternal warrior Tyson helm you know
first of all it looks like your Roman
centurion it is one of the most dominant
satellite kneel before God in my clan
like these ones probably destiny he used
to just wear that helmet just because
the way it looked
yeah you didn't care that it wasn't
functional he just loved the way it look
so when I told him
yo it's coming back he was like really
so he's been trying to burn through
faded engrams he's trying everything to
get that out of it but yeah eternal
glory be so real domine majors like and
then something else fell like the
warlocks the stag really cool looking
but you're waiting for whatever it is on
death like whenever I do my videos I'm
always saying I don't know where all the
I like I may not be the expert on where
all of them rank but if you have to wait
for something to prom yeah yeah that's
not very useful like dearly doing it
that can be an additional piece maybe
just like a bonus but yeah I think
they're afraid with so many the exotic
armors to make them the game changers
that now they've done it with the
weapons so we're gonna see but so many
of them are so minor like okay like
celestial is like if you're running
around and you're a hunter unless you're
being your you're running celestial
that's like your one go to absolutely so
knucklehead radar I have radar locate
that does squat further 0 for PvE you
mean be like let like okay so if you
have knucklehead radar on and you have
that thing on say you start tagging
enemies and if you look at them on their
tag they take more damage right I don't
know but I was like you gotta give if
they want to be a PDE in PvP thing I
mean they may not be equal but some
basic stuff like yeah we need a little
more so absolutely
they they got they did well with the
weapons they stepped outside of the box
I mean Darcy doing 4x damage you've got
tractor cam and suppressing stuff with a
void multiplier now
I mean things are better not everything
got a buff that I feel like it needed
something so could use some work but I
agree some of them got enough of a buff
some did not
but those bigger leaps I want to see
some bigger leaps with the armor and
they'll go through and pass and do some
weapons again later but they need some
massive jumps to make some armor really
stand out so I actually am torn between
yes crap what do I want those decisions
to be tough and if we can get to that
then I'll be happy so absolutely so
we've got exactly sandbox exotic armor
sandbox changes I guess phase one for
May and it says July it says more exotic
conversations to set so they won't all
be at the same time and maybe if one
tweaks and it sucks there's too much
that'll be there round two
but speaking of July's event I don't
know when yet so let me pick your
Tuesday and put your finger on a
calendar we'll see if you're right
but first we got your solstice of heroes
seasonal event interesting
so solstice any shot in the dark what
that's gonna be the summer solstice
which is typically like less ones on
Thursday June 21st so when we put it
towards late June so that's literally a
month later we're getting an event
potentially if they're doing it for
solstice mm-hmm so any shot in the dark
of what this thing's you know just I
mean not really I mean I'm just kind of
thinking you know some type of unique
summer thing I'm thinking like almost
like summer dawning kind of a deal yeah
like really bright yeah yeah I'm
thinking that something seasonal and um
you know it'll be interesting how they
handle it um as long with a caveat as
long as it's not festival of the cost
level well I would say for crimson they
learned they got their hope so they got
their kind of stuff kicked back at him
pretty fast and crimson was a quick
turnaround they were throwing in grams
at you if you wanted to go for the
exotics it was a checklist like it was
better on that front so they learned a
tough lesson and made a fairly fast
switch so that was actually
to see so I'm hoping ever verse seems to
be in a better spot and the question I
got is that um I wonder if um
we haven't heard much from srl I've
heard nothing and well is going like
low-key away so I'm wondering maybe they
might try to sneak that in like I would
I would like it but I was like I wish
they would just be like in September and
SRL is just always there yes leave it
out there as a nominee and because if
sometimes I'm just like I just want to
go drive my spare I just want to race
for a little bit and I don't have like a
Forza that I want to pick up I was like
I know it's not for everybody but it's
just like people thought it doesn t want
to make Sparrow racing leagues like hey
you're gonna go around Mars you're gonna
come back here we're gonna set up our
runs like they fought hard for it now
maybe it might not have been as popular
as people had hoped we had some fun with
it I'm using mostly cosmetics but you
know sparrows are one of those things we
use on most planets mercury we got
gypped but most of the planets you can
but the sparrows are at least like that
would be a way to hype up so it cuz most
of they all do the same thing they all
you want the 160 Sparrow that someone's
quickly and then whatever else is so be
it Blake have that time have Sparrow
racing be an option to where for one you
bring back some of the tricks where you
can have some fun with them and to get
some more perks on those sparrows get
some crazy ones in there like have just
I don't know if you're gonna do sparrows
give me something that actually lasts
afterwards that I want to use as opposed
to something I've got that's already 160
give me a say you like give me something
to grind for me there's a 170 sparrow
and it's like what's the big difference
in driving around a sparrow that's a
little faster it doesn't change much in
the world of gameplay but if you had a
right balance man is so like scared to
do that cuz there's like okay so say you
had to win a hundred a Tsar had to win
100 races and you got a like a legendary
herb sorry an exotic sparrow that's like
177
just faster than everybody else but you
worked your ass off for it I'm with that
the only thing is they're gonna have to
balance it by making that said sparrow
like damage you know resistance is lower
I'm telling you to come you know how to
community get oh he's winning I can't
beat him you know how to get with this
yeah and I just want to say suck it up
buttercup
they're so for those that never played
World Iraq war World of Warcraft you may
hate these references but there's a
reason it's brought up in relation to
destiny because destiny tinkers was
being that type of game but is always
afraid to do it so that being said there
were weapons in World of Warcraft that
were their versions of legendaries or
their versions of epics or even a step
above where literally like one person in
a clan of 40 would have a weapon it took
like an entire group to run an instance
you'd have one piece drop then another
piece whatever one piece bot drop and if
it's the guild guild leader who's like
the tank of your entire team of 40 they
have that weapon because they make your
whole group successful but they're the
only ones I mean you're gonna have a
really short list and a hard grind and
it's limited supplies that drop I mean
not everybody had that stuff and that's
some of the pieces not everybody gets
everything and I'm sorry to say it and
that's one of those that made you belong
I know you are but this is one of those
it's like go play Mega Man 3 tell me how
much you beat your head against not fair
about this I don't have the time
commitment to play srl like you and I
shouldn't be penalized because you have
worked super hard and got the the super
fast you know you're telling me if I put
time in and put effort in and you
deserve the same thing I do and if you
say yes that's the wrong thing with a
whole lot of stuff so that random preach
aside is just one of those pieces like I
would love to see stuff that is so elite
and hard to get you I like the fact that
redder exclaim more is in there diggin
that yeah we need some more stuff on the
PvE side yeah give us some more of that
stuff yes put a random couple things in
nightfalls put a random couple things in
the prestige layers have some stuff that
you've gotta like work through and fight
for and not everybody's gonna get the
same stuff but those who do it's like
holy crap I want to grab I mean that's
how you build up some of that
type is actually getting stuff in the
game that's hard to get to exactly if
you engagement of one to strive to get
it people would play that's why the
people will play trials everything would
play you know whatever these activities
were cuz that you Strout you stroll for
it man you wanted that item yep so I I
think they're learning their lesson the
making destiny to for the casual
audience was a mistake and that's part
of why I said go listen to that podcast
from DCP absolutely they've learned
they're like okay we tried to make you
know it more of a fashion show because
people complain they wanted to wear
different stuff and they're like okay
well now we're getting a lot of pushback
because armor doesn't matter mmm no like
on their side they can't win they're
trying to appease audiences and they're
like okay who keeps playing your game
people like us on the podcast if
anybody's listening to this who watches
who's still watching destiny and not
playing fort neat I mean those are your
people that want to play the game and
those are the ones who are gonna stick
with it those are the ones who have to
give them a reason to stay around I have
a buddy who I did I mean he's my destiny
buddy I couldn't even get him back for
warmind
Wow I've got people like that two men
shout out and like I said it was last
I'll be my Lords podcast I mean I had a
bloody knuckles I had a couple people on
and these guys are hurt man they're like
I'm not coming back you know maybe
September will see that it's that the
December September has to be huge enough
to do it and that's and that's where it
is like it is it's kind of limping along
like us that are in there that's like
okay we know there's a word to say hey
come back it might be decent to check
out but is it the be-all end-all we
gotta wait for September so absolutely
that aside yeah I'm not saying get good
but just don't just know that not
everybody gets everything and I think
that would make a lot of life better
there you go there you go
not everybody gets to be an Elon Musk
Bounty's we've talked about before I'm
still excited to see where they take
these whether it's exotic values
reserved whether it's bounties through
Zavala for the week I don't know what
they're gonna be crucible bounties that
are not your challenges that you have to
go if you can't if you have to be in the
crystal match to know what you're
working on you
don't even know how to build a loadout
me I sit next to a computer with dim so
I mean I have my I had it literally I
can be like in the match I'm like oh I'm
working unless I can throw it in between
deaths if I want to not anybody has that
option if you're like sitting and you go
to the town you're like hey these are my
cruises even if he's got the challenges
just like you're working through the
iron banner ornaments even if you go to
the tower and he's holding the bounties
and you can look and then come back and
check your progress at least it's a
place to look at them as opposed to
being in games yes if you're in a
crucible event I should be focused on
fighting not hold on let me click the
button run delay and okay there's the
challenges like say I'll randomly run
around up you know patrol map and all
the side and do a challenges like oh
loose like I shouldn't oops a challenge
that's yeah not a right completely agree
prestige raid layers hopefully will be
coming in July finally do with that I
mean that's no offense to anything
that's too little too late for most of
this cuz you wanted to that's yeah I
mean let people grind up let people get
up there maybe a month at a max what I
mean by the time this is out so many
people have moved on get moved on from
it
PC clan chat yes you're one triumphs
this is a new addition yeah what you get
I think I'm thinking that a triumph I'm
thinking that um you know I'm seeing
record books in our future that's what
I'm saying I'm seeing that they may have
some type of record book situation you
know unique armor sets unique things
tied to it you know they probably gonna
want us to go about the vibe I'm getting
since warmind they're learning they're
learning about minutia they're learning
about us with collectibles they're
learning about that we'd love to do all
that stuff that we didn't have and that
being input in um been warmer and I
think is their expounding upon and I
think they may have some real cool
things tied to this you know one triumph
so maybe you know I guess I mean the
only truly thing triumphantly though is
like okay yeah we did three relays oh
okay but it's curious to see how they
character how they're gonna categorize
it that's I mean trials I don't know if
it's gonna be in there but I definitely
didn't quote make it to the lighthouse
Destiny one I've not been to the top
this time never
not even close Oh we'll see I like the
idea of record books I hope they keep
bringing those back it was nice to have
a red record book for taking King they
was Kissin later like as a reason to
come back before the next thing
give me like some pages in the start of
September and then add pages throughout
the year be like hey here's like
crucible phase 2 or see just more things
to work on because that's just another
thing to grind for mm-hmm just nice to
see it more frequently than just drop a
new book at the end of the year so and
more exotic sandbox changes we know
let's just I gotta wait and see just
crossing fingers there if they move
birthday month got share eternal war
you're right they're calling it throne a
warrior July if it's good if it's
actually good this is my highest thing
right now that's why I'm wearing it
September gear collections records we
know weapons slot changes weapon
randomizations big ones make shebangs
yeah those are all the ones they're
waiting to see for the big things and
they're gonna have to III is gonna be
interesting I don't know if they're
gonna talk about that stuff in more
detail yet if they're gonna do their
little reveal streams for it the new
gameplay mode is the big one so some of
you guys may have seen Call of Duty's
stream yesterday mm-hmm and okay and
we've got blackout band conference over
no details I'm like really really pissed
off about that just because like give me
something like we have battle royale
games out there we know how they work it
is a blatte a battle royale game now I'm
wondering is this to be battle royale
September well not even that for one on
battlenet because it's Activision so
Activision's just using battlenet for PC
so I'm good with that but my what I had
heard and I have no idea if this is true
or not but they didn't have a campaign
because it wasn't gonna come together in
time so my wondering is if blackout is
quiet for now because they're still
putting it together it's possible it's
possible I wouldn't put anything past
them yeah so I mean they've got till
October so I mean they're dropping
teasers they might get little blips they
might have a tiny section that works or
something like that but I don't think
it's gonna be battle royale for destiny
yeah I don't think so either I mean it
would be weird I don't think it really
fits you know fits in that space
I mean I'm curious know because
Activision they want that money so I'm
curious to see what this mode is but I
mean we know the people I went to the
community summit
you know they can't talk about it but
again they had they said it's not
something we've never seen in destiny
and it's amazing
I've got confirmation for multiple
sources that I trust yeah most people
were just like I don't want to stop
playing and I was like well what is it
what is I know like it's driving me nuts
to try to figure out what this could
possibly be you know um we got a tree
coming so hopefully maybe we get a
little sneak peek I don't know it's
gonna be interesting I think that'd be a
good time to drop it to build hype it
sounds like it was playable so it sounds
like it's it's at a point they could
show it absolutely well I'm hoping they
do give some type of teaser maybe
gameplay on the floor mm-hmm that that
would be the way you build up
September's you've got to have some new
hook because if it's just possible story
the people like it's Destiny's story
whoo
you know it's like the weapon
randomization the slot change is
bringing it back that steps but it's
like they need a big big reason to pull
people back and absolutely III is the
big table to do it on so really great
no idea what it is just can't wait to
find out wait what else we got oh that's
pretty much it for the road map so a few
changes we know armors come in sooner
we've got the may update July's got you
know triumphs and we'll see what
bounties are gonna do and just all that
stuff is leading to September it's
overall generally I mean my thoughts
have wore mine so far we said it last
time I gave it about a C+ because things
are not perfect I mean the grind was not
balanced right and I'll cover some of
that here in a little bit light as I
mean Dustin said it most people have in
some way or another the ship is turning
in a good direction yes bring it towards
yeah headed towards progress lots of
good lots of communication mm-hmm good
stuff across the board so you go ahead
and jump into the club this weekend run
g12 time time so basically they said
they've covered some of the basics of
what people have done so far
one person r2 got legend yeah that's
crazy
then what was his name but one second
kill I think something like that mm yeah
so he was the first what he's at least
probably the first public person with
the red Rex's Claymore and he's the
first one in the legend status now
granted he'd probably had a good team to
run with he's been working his butt off
he had 97 win streak that is insane
saying like so I think the win streaks
what like a 3 or 5 bonus and then he see
I know about to lose streaks those 1 I
know about like oh you got a little
points while they're gone there you go
yeah so we'll get to a glory discussion
here a little bit farther down and they
got some stuff to say about that
but it's cool to see like someone
grinded there like people wanted to do
world's first and raids that's what they
said some people want to do raid he
fought his tail off for world's first
legend and I mean II mean that's that's
a grind right there that's no joke I
don't want it Laurie want to play
against him
thanks but yeah because they threw the
roadmap up there again so you can see it
so our first piece of the club is
powerful progress and this is kind of
what we were teasing about before but it
was one to say so they basically said
war mind is out we know progress is one
of those things that people have issues
with we hittin walls at certain points
basically if you know and you've played
this at all about 345 you hit a brick
wall like swear on just faceplant and
it's rough now you've got your powerful
engrams so that will get you slowly
above that right now those who did
regular raid prestige raid raid lair and
trials like yeah they got a boost
but as dad oh did his video he's like ok
so you have how many milestones like six
I think yeah something like that and
then he's like okay so then if you do
all the raids and trials and those other
encounters you have 21 options versus 6
yeah so and that's from 340 up now one
of the main issues and this is gonna be
my little explosion you can focus for
later go for it and dado had the same
thing to say he just beat it to it cuz
we were doing it today but it was like
as soon as we loaded in and you saw
heroic strikes for 350 you're like cool
there
you finished one which by the way if
you're doing grounded
y'all older burn yeah I was doing the
one with the worm getting roasted
finally for about like six nests and I
get a 340 drop and I want to punch my
monitor yeah it's great they're harder
than a nightfall these overall extract a
harder than the nightfall yeah well cuz
the normal night falls at 270 exact
level which is right no it's like that's
an issue like I don't know how they
balance out cuz from what I've heard and
people have said it a couple places and
they have certain pieces either at night
falls at 270 or the raids are low
because you can't satisfy the basically
the trophies and the achievements yes
yeah and that allows them not it doesn't
allow them to get certification so
they're trying to find ways to that I'm
like okay so have an or have like have a
normal night fall yes has a higher night
fall have your prestige nightfall have
your like base night fall that you could
even do matchmaking on and maybe you're
in Graham on that one
maybe that is 340 because it's your
matchmaking and you want 340 or maybe
it's like you know somewhat below you or
so or somewhere similar like a you know
medium nightfall a you know a guardian
nightfall or whatever and that's your
middle ground that's your one that
sticks with your expansions and keep
enticing and then you have your prestige
where it absolutely royally kicks your
butt you can crank it up modifiers all
that stuff like just add another one in
there and that's the same thing he was
saying it's just like there has to be a
way to not have a nightfall be 270 right
but still they still skew your power
level to whiskers do it yeah but then
you go into a heroic strike at 350 and I
was 340 and holy crap I got my bow upped
yeah it's no joke like there's really
yeah I got absolutely lit up but then
you work your tail off or something and
the loot doesn't even matter you know
that that's egregious and um and yes
shout out to me having to do three a
time not to cut you I'm sorry
no no go for it no I was gonna say just
shout out to me having two three of
those as part
oh excuse
that's Paula West I tried Fievel and we
know what was worse one of the five I
had to do over because of the heroic
strike glitch thankfully that it's fixed
yeah yeah but it's just like dude those
with no I literally I was like wow dude
these are Bruhl certain modifiers are
ridiculous and to just open that chest
at the end and tonight you know I'm
gonna give them a better surprisingly
though I'm gonna give them the benefit
of the battle this only because how are
you giving them in the benefit of that
with any right mind think that anybody
with any common sense could have planned
that would would hope that this was an
oversight that they forgot to they were
so happy to put modifiers it gotta bump
I mean that's a given in the benefit
that now but so much of this is curated
you know that wasn't oh yeah I mean the
soft cap they're like yeah 340 and then
you're gonna do the in-game grind well
then your heroic strikes or 340 then
yeah three like either one way the other
heroic strikes go down to what you get
the gear for but then you give no reason
to do them which I think it sucks or you
bring them up and you have what they're
gonna do which is not quite right nice
last weeks on this so they want to make
the progress better we know escalation
protocol kicks your butt no I'm here in
that 350 360 Rome you're not quite
getting whooped og you can survive you
can survive but the damage is not there
yet to be able to start getting those
guys so I mean I've got a level two but
that wizard does not die wizard he met
wizard oh that wizard like I've seen it
go down maybe a quarter or and maybe
about a third like I've taken down the
over a couple times with a decent sized
group and they're probably about my
level but that wizard he's just like nah
you know not touch just health versus
art damaged no protocol they say the key
fragments will be a 100 percent drop
from every heroic strikes we're giving
you incentive I don't know what those do
yeah I'm just about to ask you I don't
recall what these are yeah like I feel
I'm gonna look at my inventory you go no
because I'm sitting and I'm like oh I
hope they do they okay to initiate it no
those are the ones that open the chest
for the arm
at level seven oh uh first of all about
yeah totally yeah but basically I'm not
even finishing it out but that's fine
well what they do that I think it's
seven key fragments you put them
together and that way when you get to
level seven
you actually can open the chests for the
armoire this was a special choice they
almost doing like a rat to the Machine
style well you got like the fragments
and they I put them to get now you
wouldn't get those fragments from like
different levels or something like that
but to open the chest like you got to
have that so don't go random upon you
know happen across the level seven kill
yourself wearing it not have a key cuz
you're not gonna open the chest you so
that's cool it's a pretty much giving
you a component for an end game
escalation thing based on as a heroic
strike drop hundred-percent that's
actually pretty cool yeah so it's
something it's a good thing to grind for
us there'll be more people in there too
which will be doing hopefully some more
high-level people working on the tough
stuff now the other side I have a tweak
already just by reading it I'm kinda
like I don't quite agree so currently
the drops are like 340 right just that's
your legendaries your blues are like 335
they're not just the below okay the
Blues are like 340 they're stuck heroic
strikes will be able to drop better
rewards every three to five heroic
strikes will drop a legendary that can
carry you up to 360 okay now talk to me
the fact that is three to five how long
did it take you to do three strikes roll
especially if you're dying on a boss
fight yeah you're right the ship wisent
and not or consistent I get you know I
think you know what they doing they're
doing it through the five to try to
throttle you know what I do is people
are gonna stay in the strikes and not do
the raid or not do the thing and that
they're trying to still throttle they
want investment that's what you want
playing strikes for a little while
longer maybe maybe if you do two strikes
in a row it's every two to four and
maybe if you do three strikes in a row
and you stay in there for a while it's
every one to three so the longer you
play maybe it throttles down a little
bit more
now I up to 360 but that way if you
grind strikes for a while and you got up
to 340 you need your bile stones okay
I'm gonna go grind this I want to get
maybe at least ten levels and I agree
you know you're not gonna get every
piece even if you get something up to
360 and it's like Sam 350 and I get
something 350 - it's still gonna take a
while in there so if they can stagger
that a little more maybe you give you
incentives to stay in there if you got a
good if you got a crappy group bail like
oh yeah I'm not gonna hang with him but
you find a good group hang with them
keep burning out strikes and whittle
away slowly at that level at least a
creep a little closer and that's exactly
what they had in d1 cuz you remember
there used to be that on that Vanguard
yeah Vanguard boost that you'd get you
know and you do even wouldn't you be
able to UM get higher rewards with that
and wouldn't that like also increase
back then like skeleton key you know
chant fall stuff to that effect yeah all
that stuff was in there so that would be
I like I mean I may be close to 360 on a
character by the end of the week I'm
probably not gonna be quite there so I
would probably wouldn't grind that much
so some people like hey by the time this
comes out on the 29th this is gonna be
too late I'm already gonna be 360 are
you 380 on everyone any characters if
you are you have played a buttload more
than that so for most of us who are like
hey I'm working on one character maybe
bouncing to the other for some quick
milestones but not grinding as much
right this is gonna help your grind of
other characters this is gonna be for
like my brother who gets to play like
once or twice a week with kids and
everything else so this is not for
everybody get Thalian straight up set it
this is not for everybody if you're
already up there it's not for you this
is this is to help the progression I
mean this is even like dados rant to say
difficulty of the the things should
match the drops like everything
everything is based on your power level
and then you have those soft caps in
there and they don't stagger the
progression that way and it's kind of
rough like let's get that strikes are
like they feel tacked on because there's
never typically incentive to do them
this is at least somewhat of an
incentives or the key fragments but it's
like say you go through the story you're
340 say you do regular strikes with some
random people and matchmake
maybe that gets you up to 350 no but
it's likes like but it's a slog from 345
to 350 or so say you want to jump up to
350 okay so tharam you know 350 345 to
350 five heroic strikes they're gonna
help you a little bit give you some
quicker drops those the last five levels
might slow you down
powerful engrams are still gonna help
and then as you go through you can throw
some in-game in there and that's the way
you give different people different
things to do but you're not feeling like
you're constantly doing stuff and not
making progress mm-hmm or on the other
end you don't do all your milestones and
then you turn the game off for the week
like you need some balance between those
and I know they have a tough line to
walk but you need some continual
progression where activities different
harder activities progress through like
I mean regular strikes heroic strikes
nightfall strikes that's a logical
progression yeah it should be it should
be that way with your gear - no I agree
I listen I know I know you're at and I'm
not saying you're wrong you're
absolutely right this is this is an
oversight you know Dave this is that you
know between a soft cap hard cap and
this comes down to rewarding hard
content I'm with that I guess I'm wrong
excuse me I guess I'm more confident
that this is gonna get resolved quickly
because I feel that they get it though
they get what they did right with warm
run is they understood content needed to
be hard there had to be a grind again
and I love that about woman actually I
loved an escalation protocol I love that
the rate is heart where they messed up
now is like okay you got it that it's
are but you're not rewarding said
difficulty enough and you're not
rewarding heroic strikes you're not
rewarding that the referee the mother
spider stars rain is that people these
are hawk orators saying yo this thing is
hard I didn't finish it or it was like
30 people finished over the weekend as
opposed to the like woman's leather raid
layer the you know apartment duty two
hours maybe it was done and like
everybody had it done like it took 12
hours and I was like 30 teams that
finished it over the weekend like that's
brutal but that's what I wanted to hear
that was amazing I do I love to hear
that all I want to hear now in
conjunction with it is
oh my god I got this insane weapon or oh
my god like almost you know I mean like
like to see that I believe it was like a
fusion in the side oh my come on no you
cannot do that no you cannot have your
hardest six person absolute beating like
the Vicarious Visions 4b can everybody
like you know themselves occasionally be
like him I still work it like holy crap
like shout out to them but yeah if you
give us crap rewards like if I carry us
may have billed the encounter and then
Bungie unfortunately was in charge of
the war it's like mm-hmm and you can't
do that later you cannot be afraid like
they came for the raid perks and the
regular raid David and that was on the
armor those little mods yes
like you've got to make those guns stand
out you've got to make them PPE monsters
right you got to make those mods double
up you got to have that mod and still be
able to put another martyr like so you
got it done something you just like give
us some like awesome perks choices let
me pick between rampage say you finish
that Indian and see you get like
desperado on the hand cannon from the
rate you want to tell people be granted
for something that new rhetorics is
claim or perk and you got to finish the
prestige pain in the butt raid lair hold
yeah I mean little little stuff but it's
like I want them to go even farther than
like two extra perk slots two extra
months lots like yes great it's got to
be worth it exactly they had some stuff
before but even the raid guns but like
he taken King had a couple good guns
yeah but then some like sniper was
decent pulse rifles decent shotgun I
think was good those are machine guns
yeah that's about it it had like the
worst hand cannon Thor's auto rifle I've
probably ever seen and destiny I was
like those two strange how does a raid
gun get set up that way later if you
have hand cannons in the game it should
be it's one of the top what out it out
so so their work
I mean again one thing is at least
they've acknowledged in the bar I will
in hurry with that problem see that is
something that I'm looking at positively
I'm like before we would make these you
know flash points and we complain like
what were they thinking right
hey all this time we're thinking we know
what they're thinking it's all mostly a
couple we apologize we realize that this
is not enough reward and incentive we
are on it that's what I need to hear
yeah
and that I do it I was like and don't
don't get me wrong I appreciate that
huge because this is the fastest
addressing of like it was it's eight
days and the other thing hey this
progression isn't right and we're
working on it in a week and a half like
that's the fastest I've ever seen them
turn around something with like
progression and reward dropping and
power level like that is a fast
tournament that is crazy good so I
really really do appreciate that so
again if you can hold off for eight days
go try Detroit or state of decay good
luck I have no idea how that's gonna go
I've seen questionable things but hold
your breath like take a week and then
you know this will be in effect so it's
like that's as fast as they can possibly
get it out now some people like well you
can hug folks to go in but you can do
this it takes a while for things to get
patch guys some things are server-side
some are client-side client-side stuff
is harder to get out because they have
to do PC Xbox Playstation certification
and all of it has to go and if you think
that's an easy process I'm not a game
developer I can only imagine that as a
royal pain in the butt yeah so I was
like the fact that they can even try and
do this this quick hey thanks I'll take
it they're getting better so now now
they have a couple other issues they're
talking about they don't have immediate
solutions mm-hm
what am i hearing Oh weird noise sorry
No so they're trying to say that said
they're trying to smooth out the
transition into in-game grind because
they said everybody hits that brick wall
at 3:45 goes from fast to super friction
they said once milestones are completed
there Ords aren't you know rewards
aren't to chase exotic masterworks like
these are some good things exotic master
works my Darcy grind is gonna take a
while I just I've been messing around
with stuff I haven't just slowly but
slowly working on it I'm not looking 34%
but it's something I can work I'm like
oh yeah okay I can hang out patrol I can
go snipe some people I'll work on there
that's awesome stuff to do those are
good things and when those things change
over like master work what's the I want
the no I want the vigilance wing just
mountain people that's a lot oh man
and that's a rant that's a yeah random
drop-in crucible hmm but those are cool
and they said as highlighted weapon
randomization and records should give
people more to do you will see what that
is
in game progression they said it right
here it needs more peace issues right
now every everything gives similar sized
upgrades without discrete tiers in
progression and that's what they need to
do it's like that is something I
definitely wouldn't expect a solution
for prior to September but it's on their
radar so again September they're turning
the ship they're being aware it's like
people are tired of like hey I'm tired
of hitting a wall yeah absolutely
oh yeah give me a ladder to climb even
if some of the steps are bigger and
they're a little harder to get over but
you can slowly finish it up like maybe
three forty five to three fifty that's a
hard to grind three like those little
pieces are harder but you can at least
know if I'm going through run and strike
okay cool I got that next thing it's a
little bit higher it's like I mean so
they're trying to about we wanted it all
spoon-fed to us we got it thrown at us
and then we had no reason to play the
other taking it the other way which is
good and then they're just trying to
walk that balance and find it without
doing it too far so I appreciate they're
not just instantly rolling it back which
is good and they're just trying to walk
it out so just go ahead no I'm just an
acknowledgment is where I'm at right now
and the fast turnaround and the fast
response is positive signs to me so you
know I'm actually a minute the place I'm
not in my normal rent mode right now
with them on this cuz I'm like okay I
didn't even had to say nothing you
already said you know like I was ready
to lash them and then they like okay
hold on we understand I'm good with that
let's get the implementation going and
let's go yeah my rent may have been a
little early because I forgot this yeah
yeah but I still wanted to say it
because as someone like if you were
sitting there as a game tester I'd be
like yeah that still needs fixed facts
so now here's where your sections coming
up whoa let's go going for glory
so for progression isn't just achieving
new levels of power also looking how
people are progressing through the ranks
of valor and glory so they're looking at
a couple questions about the competitive
playlists in general so do you want me
to ask these questions yeah yeah let's
go
gonna get to yours yeah let's go so
people have had questions about glory
and matchmaking and all that stuff going
on so why would I match against a player
with a higher glory rank than me mm-hmm
they said there's a couple of reasons
actually here all us the question you
answer so you say they say they for
variety reasons they don't want to match
it directly on your glory number they're
using it per playlist skill value it's
quite likely the opponent it's a good
match against you but they'd be grinding
glory more consistently so they move the
rank faster take this as a sign that
you'll likely reach that rank with
continued play yeah I have a feeling
about that [ __ ] should I get into that
now should we do this the one question
that I'm gonna tell ya like I'm not
exactly sold on this um I play glory a
lot now um I played as a team and
actually it's gonna go into the next
question so let me not get into that
party's yet but I will say I still not
really sure about that system because
I've seen me go up against the same
teams consistently and I'm still not
sure that whatever this algorithm that
they're using and apparently they just
patched again you know that we implement
it yeah I'm not sure man I'm not sure
I'm still thinking there needs to be
some tweaking right there but uh
continue with the next now get into my
deeper nah so why can I match make make
match against preform fire teams when
I'm searching as a solo player yeah
alright so their answer is after a bit
of service are tuning investigation they
we enabled the crucible fire team
matchmaking that's what I was talking
about earlier this does not directly
reduce your chances of matching against
pre-made fireteam but does tweak the
skill values of those fire teams to make
it more likely that they find evenly
matched ponies I still don't think this
is working as intended because like I
said I started off as a team we were
kind of pub stomping we were kind of
doing well we backed until we matched up
against some other good teams I didn't
have a problem with us losing those
matches what I did have a problem was
playing as so long and um there was a
time I got pups dogs you know a guy
dropped okay whatever
yeah you know I got pop stomping fair
square okay whatever
then I looked at it and I'm like wait a
minute these gamertags look familiar I
literally got on a three Lou streak
it was the same guys and they were like
it was like two out of the four time was
still wasn't a clan together they would
it was they were still Mac together and
I'm like this algorithm is where I need
to be and dude in glory them losses hurt
man number one you go on a law streak
and you just see at the end of the match
this circle whittle down and you're they
taking right go ahead like and say do
you think law streaks should be a thing
I'm torn I'm torn part of me says yes
really I'm torn I am it's a tough one um
maybe not cuz here's the thing you want
this activity to be difficult right I
know I know the argument against it like
yo that's just not right it's
demoralizing it's you know it shouldn't
be factored into this kind of thing most
games don't do it if they get rid of it
don't get me wrong I wouldn't be like oh
I need to bring law strings back no no
I'm not all I'm saying is is that I
don't mind it only for the simple fact
that yo it you know if analyzes if you
go on a bad run and I don't mind that my
thing is I just don't like going on a
bad run when there's things out of my
control like I shouldn't be like do what
I'm noticing is let's say you know I'm
doing you know glory survival right
first team to four wins and you every
all teams have a pool of lives right
yeah I'm noticing as soon as it's two
old dudes are dropping the match and I'm
like wow it says such a such departed
this person departed like I have no
chance right now at that point you got
to do something for the people who
stayed in it I'm not saying you know
like either I cut the streaks something
it's just not fair to be dudes are
dropping and I'm curious for the guys
that are dropping if they're getting
penalized at all because if they're not
that sucks yeah yeah we're getting to
the next question
there's no ready for this one somewhere
to talk about why wouldn't you make a
solo queue only playlist yeah so their
answer you don't want to do that because
it would split the population in an
unhealthy way making it less likely for
everyone to find that matches
furthermore that would probably mean
splitting the ranked solo glory and team
glory and we'd rather be one single
number to represent your prowess on
crucible shout out the BK bed-stuy to
Chad he made a good place it could it be
the algorithm was forced because the
play the same people because they had a
lack of plays it's possible it's very
much possible and I think that's all
this is I mean let's keep it real with
the Destiny's base right now right it's
not the game is slowly trying to recover
the majority of the high count they
start off what it's not there so yeah
play account could definitely play a
factor here and I think that's why
they're terrified and doing it because
the numbers probably would indicate that
they don't have that population to do it
it just sucks like it just sucks as a
solo player to be matched up against
these like super sweaty crazy tryhard
rederick screw I for dudes wit rhetorics
I'm like come on that's the crucible
beast like what are you gonna do and
then some people are saying it's like
you know if you're soloing it's like
it's not gonna be the fastest guns still
some other stuff is gonna be better but
it's like if they get that perk active
you're done you're not gonna win you
know and eNOS the other thing is like
okay you know what's that heavy spawn
and do is control the heavy and you know
they jump out to a big lead the problem
I have is dudes are not due to the
losing teams are not completing the
match no that's oblem and that should be
one of those like if you if you leave I
don't know what the penalty is yeah it
even still there they I haven't seen any
penalty that's the thing like I need to
I'm low key because my honor I'm such a
problem person like I'm low key wanna
test out cheatin and just jumping out
the match as soon as I know it's a
foregone conclusion that the team will
lose anyone can happen what happens you
know I mean because it's happening way
too frequent for me to think that yo
these dudes ain't getting penalized
they're like literally one match
it was I thought like it was literally
the entire fireteam versus me everybody
on my squad bounced as soon as they was
getting stopped I mean that's the part
where hopefully you start dancing and if
they're not absolutes hurts they might
dance with you but honestly for you as
you finish either you stay in that match
for one you have to wait on time which
kind of sucks for the other team and
then two if you do finish there's no way
you're going to win so honestly like if
like if someone leaves a competitive
match that match should not count
against you because lately you're not to
win that's what I'm saying there should
be some type of buff that either stops
the losing streak you know you know
something you have to reward the guy who
stuck it out and took his loss like a
man right got a reward that guy you
cannot penalize him as if he's the worst
like and these dudes are running out and
trying to get into another session like
nah so they gotta fix that that's a big
deal for me I actually tweeted out to
him but you're Barrett I believe all who
else put it out on I think it was cactus
was putting it out like hey welcome to
Glory crucible you know you know
finishing matches by himself or what I
would have instead and that's the
problem they said we'll get to the other
question here real quick just add it in
so we can talk about it why would you
place me in a game in progress that you
know I'm going to lose and in my streak
and they said there's no joint in
progress in competitive yeah but they
joint out yeah they said they they there
is one they're working on a fix for
valor and the other playlist so won't
lose your valor that way I'm like so
similar situation if you're in
competitive competitive and somebody
leaves you're literally at a
disadvantage so therefore it's not equal
just be like hey we're gonna go ahead
and call this a draw like if you lose
and left just call it a draw or let the
let the other team have their points
it's not the end maybe give them less
maybe even less depending on how far you
are into it but you finish it out if
somebody leaves and again somebody's
connection could have dropped somebody's
kid might think that you never know what
it is mm-hmm but let that be a way to be
like alright this match is done if
somebody leaves no on foot you're like
here's the thing though I'm having
situations where two people - and three
people are dropping great and
there should be an algorithm at that
point not everybody lost a connection
say no no and that's a point for you
like if you're like everybody leaves and
you play for like another minute and be
like okay yeah this dude's neutral he's
not moving the other guys on the other
side and if it was like if it's for 240
yeah they stopped you give them a win
you get a nothing no lost no win no
streak effect just great you know
nullify that loss yes and then just move
on to the next one these mortals and
have something in there don't match them
up against the same people like they
gotta have an algorithm kind of like how
they had the algorithm when you had the
repeat strike yeah you can see people
you just fought you for that next match
can't see like I don't mind if it's two
matches but the next match you should
not be matched up with the exact same
dudes sweaty waiting eat I got like a
mercy in that that day or something like
if you got mercy by that crew yeah fun
for anybody who nobody wants to get
stomped now I will say on the other side
again one of these like suck it up
buttercup moments because have you ever
been in a match you start behind on a oh
you jump in but yes right back yes that
is some of the best feelings to be like
oh we almost and that's the point I may
not win those but I'm not in it I'm not
in it to for the win because Valerie is
not gonna hurt anything but that fight
back that struggle is see if we can play
with my team art I'm really gonna focus
with my team here like stay together and
see what you can do that's how you get
better that's how you get better shot
the moments it's out to fill in as chase
like you know their number of times I
finished my crucible matches when I'm
getting beat down it hurts when I got
that streak going but yeah shoutout to
you for finishing like these dudes ain't
finishing and I don't see no penalties
I'm not hearing about no penalties so
yeah like I agree like there's those
moments when you do come back and you
feel good like they gotta get better
with that they gotta read what they got
to figure something out cuz I'm Tara is
real salt in that glory man that glory
I jumped into one of those on PC and I
was like I gotta find some people cuz
solo it C is just gonna be a beating
they shout out to my boy sinister super
gangster we had a squat my boy anyone
[ __ ]
we four deep it's a different man it's a
difference like we won 70% of the
matches you don't saying cuz again it
was max max at max matching I can't talk
against people of similar skill and then
he started to progressively get harder
and harder and then there was one of the
master we just ain't really know that it
was a new map and I'd an island you know
this map and it was kind of like when
he's not with the heavy was really
centralized and people were just
wondering for the heavy you know saying
kind of dig so we like Dan yeah I can
show that heavy room next time we do
this map because we didn't know it but I
took that loss well I'm okay we learned
the minute I got to like that almost a
next rank of all glory something I cool
my boy so let me see if I did not lose
damn near all the glory I gained for the
weekend
[Music]
on a streak and it just kept evaporating
the black no yeah yeah see that right
there is why I don't think the loss
trick should be in there right now if
you lose that's one thing and maybe you
even temper the losses a little bit but
until they have that matchmaking right
until they have some of these things
figured out until solo queue matches
like I don't know how they're
matchmaking works like my assumption and
it's just random BS numbers say you have
a random skill level 1000 all four of us
do so if I'm a solo person and I'm gonna
match make we add up as for people who
equal about a thousand for skill level
okay other team for people who are a
thousand but they are matched up so
they're communicating their team what do
you do to their skill level do you make
it 1.5 so you make them 6,000 and that's
their skill because they're a team yeah
so then for solos at like a 1500 versus
a thousand versus that team of thousand
working together might be that even
playing field but as a people or if you
have four people at 1500 as a team
they're bumped all the way up to like
9,000 see that's where it's like I don't
know how they're doing the math but it
was like you need a substantial jump
when you have a team because of how this
game effects that it needs to be like a
2x get something like major
because even because this is all oh guys
at a disadvantage man it's just a shot
he is so massive you can't have it this
little be like oh maybe like 1.01 mm-hmm
no it's not gonna be like there one
person change in Auto rifle damage you
can't have that it needs to literally be
like twice as much or something I think
actually like that change you're talking
actually like that I think that's like
good idea I mean I don't know how the
numbers are calculated what they do but
whatever they account for the so the
team player it needs to be a big big
buff yeah so like if you're running in
what is the middle like fabled and
you're running as a team you ought to be
playing people above you like in that
next rank if they're running yeah so I
mean that's the differences like whether
it's the glory number or whether it's
your skill number you need to be making
a substantial jump if you're shooting or
if you're solo it's harder but you're
playing teams of lower skills you might
win some more one-on-ones but you got to
do a solo fight so like yes that's where
I think some of that I mean that's good
yeah I think that's a fair trade
especially cuz solo guys can't
communicate as well so yeah I think I
think that's a great tree I like that I
would love them to implement something
like that and you cannot assume any jump
anybody jumps in the like the fireteam
chat that's in there people's like if
your solos like you got ask you it and
you just got to know so thanks you know
we got I'm done reading sweaty it's
fierce it's rough so iron clad iron
banner is returning banner we got salad
and looking fancy as always so next week
Tuesday - Tuesday it will be fake roll
control 66 is back honestly I had a lot
of fun last time this was either so I'm
happy to see it back also we have
ornaments which they look very similar
to the ones from last time now the
faction awards are cool so this is gonna
work the same ways of all of those I
don't know if the ship is gonna be like
level 50 if so that's gonna be one hell
of a grind
but because of all is like a crazy grind
but probably similar thing maybe a
little five you might get you know a
class item or something and you might
get the sidearm and then that's in and
then at 15 and then as you work through
you can get these now you might get some
lucky drops and I might
get a ship or an emblem or something
from one of my faction awards or maybe
those are in the top level so your
faction awards you'll be getting your
packages anyway but if you don't and you
want to grind for it you're just unlucky
or whatever then maybe you'll do this
stuff so I just like the fact that like
I'm okay with that type of grind if you
if you know you want to do it and maybe
like up here in the faction Awards it's
not all the same stuff or maybe these
look a little fancier it would honestly
be really cool if some of these had
different perks than your random drops
mm-hmm so just for a little more variety
but just the fact that it's gonna be
rewards his seasonal reputation of 35 if
you hit 35 in like one week you are
insane blaze it on all of season three
so you're gonna have some time to grind
for it
so yeah I'll be working on climbing the
ranks just like any other faction we got
our pictures here cool I can sniper I'm
digging this one I really like the
graphics on the rocket launch because I
like the rocket or rocket launcher look
I need some cluster bombs on that man I
hope they got some good perks for that
yeah seriously it looks like submachine
gun hand cannon sidearm and a vice scout
yeah let me get the ornaments or we get
the armor yes we've got shredder that's
all you're gonna see so you're welcome
for that I like the angles I like that I
don't know why and looks like all the
fabric on these has more weight to it
yeah I like the way they did the front
of the fabric hey yeah I don't know if
it's just the green parts you got green
and chrome you shiny so if you want to
get shiny this iron banner is for you so
should be interesting
I'm not gonna go into all this stuff
basically just if you want to read about
it they've got some companion apps
getting updated in different times user
experience accessibility ologist and
there they got some hot fixes one thing
for you guys all to know a couple pieces
for the heroic strike progress
make sure boon it will not let it count
towards your progress so you hold on to
your vanguard boons until they fix it
just save them they're not that big of a
deal anyway just don't don't pop them
yeah
but the biggest one is your clan exp
milestone for your powerful gear only
options for it I turn mine in Las Vegas
I don't know if I haven't done it that
much this way you haven't played as much
so if you do your clan exp milestone
save it win it
Auto when the reset happens at whatever
12 o'clock central time for me when that
happens it's gonna audit Achra to the
pop the proper level so just don't turn
it in let it go through the weekly reset
and then go pick it up best way to
handle it but just don't go turn it in
during the week you're gonna get 340 and
well that's just taking one of those
ways to progress away from you so pretty
sure I did that on my tight on my
warlock already so oops
yeah weekly videos you guys know those
and they have their little community PvP
Bungie vs so yeah Dillon bear he beat
him one on one two to one but destiny
community clod cast actually beat Bungie
three to two so animal split I didn't
get to watch it but I might go try and
hunt down that stream later just to see
if there's any little tidbits of
knowledge but overall pretty cool stuff
shout outs a world's first those guys
are beasts I mean they were at it a long
time though I didn't see anybody finish
it for like eight twelve hours whoever
is first it took a long time to get
through it so mm-hm
we have one more little tidbit just to
talk about real quick so we got arms
weak now this is something but like it's
not so public per se basically people
search the arms weak and this stuff
popped up I don't know how it happened
maybe somebody and this stuff just
showed so what we've got is basically
first you've got the train with
limitations let me see if I can get my
tabs right so it's hard to see let me
try and highlight it mmm
there you go so train with limitations
and a real fight will set you free lord
shaxx
so I don't know why shacks is saying
these heinous
[ __ ] your arsenal yeah either banshee
or is avala or somebody
checks your arsenal is restricted for
greater challenge use the prescribed
loadout but let no other constraint stop
your rampage so maybe and this is the
kind of war we'll get so he's the one
saying this first and this will clear up
a little bit more so we have a couple of
these arms weak nightfall the prospector
so it sounds like now I don't know if
this is hidden in code if it's not
enacted yet maybe this is part of the
summer event maybe she's gonna have
something to do hopefully it looks like
yeah they're giving him more
functionality so shut down the
operations of an ironmonger providing
weapons to the red Legion arms dealer
strike obviously and your modifiers are
gold rush so this modifier if you do it
with whatever random loaded they're
gonna give you in kind of the way
esoteric doesn't already he to some
viewer ones they could pick some nasty
ones I mean if you had to go to like a
sidearm a submachine gun and a sword go
fight yeah get in there
fall that way you're gonna be waiting on
your ammo for a while minute but gold
rush complete this nightfall to upgrade
the prospectors master work so I can
find the master or catalyst but it's
gonna take you doing this to finish it
off yeah and I maybe you guys those yeah
and then some random code down here in
the bottom but yeah forces you to to you
utilize data that weapon mastery in and
the high difficulty activity you know
this sounds cool yeah arms weak hard
hard light so gel deep into the hive
infested arcologies in search and it's
complete this nightfall to upgrade hard
lights master work and then 7 is the
racking same thing so there's some
master works that we have been able to
get to I don't know when and if this is
coming from this is just something but
it's out there and exists so there's
something strikes launches a random
destiny to or curse of Osiris strike
requiring a specific weapon loadout now
this is where I think it's weird and I
don't know where or how accurate this is
it says destiny to or curse illustrators
personal service your mind is out so I
have a feeling this text at least some
of it is old so it's yeah I think
it would say 'i need st to strike or
does need to expansion are expecting to
or have warmind listed somewhere in
there if this was like ready to go soon
so it probably had this in mind for a
long time these are just placeholders to
be honest so i don't know but this was
found recently i don't know if somebody
just popped into it by happenstance or
it's been there for a while or if it
just showed up but i mean this is the
fact that like I mean we know catalysts
are a thing so that's definitely
something so those are somewhat accurate
so if you're like okay prospector
catalyst mm-hmm okay so master works so
it's like they have a plan it's just
when these are gonna be implemented we
don't know so just wanted to throw this
out there for you guys so if you have
any thoughts on this one again comment
let us know shoot us a message on
Twitter if you have any theories I like
the idea of specific loadouts because
they haven't done that much they they
teased it for the prestige grades a
while back and they have said yeah so
they're like okay so the prestige rate
and it's like curated rate you would use
this one you'd have this modifier and
snipers and go and then next week could
be something different so giving us
specific ways and it's like arms dealer
so he's he's the bank he's the you know
he's the gunsmith you want to work on
certain guns now if this is just like
the only thing he's doing you kind of
hope there's more to it cuz right now
just mod man need some help but I missed
the packages man yeah but that I mean
those don't exist without random roles
so those aren't even gonna be an option
till the fall so I don't know what do
you think thinking it liking it I'm
digging I think listen more activities
to do you know content incentive to get
um you know what you call it master work
incentives and things like that I think
that I think they're saving a lot of
those master work for kind of activities
like that now I think this might even be
tired my gut tells me know some of the
stuff might even be tied to exotic I
mean two bounties uh time yeah I think I
think we may see some of that um I'm all
about that question man and that's why I
like you know no again toward the ends
like that's why even though war man's
not perfect
enjoying it because there's something to
be said like I'm literally in the public
space of Mars I'm doing my little I'm
they gave me a reason to do patrols now
so that I can get for them and then you
get that resonant stem you get forward I
mean you transform the for resonant
stems into that our override frequency
have you started your sleep requests at
all yeah a little bit yeah
and then it's like I'm going around the
map and then you reading the clues and
you know okay I gotta go to descent here
there's a thing there like I'm messing
around with that and then on on route of
doing that oh wow somebody jumped off
for escalation let me jump in there okay
boom below you know what you call it
jumped off so it's like for the first
time
I mean Nursing in the world so to speak
in the patrol space so to speak yeah I'm
liking it you know I'm saying so again
is it perfect no there's a lot of still
things wrong but I think they're
learning I think you know what I think
they're getting they're getting the
daily grind stuff in like they're
starting to get that night to get me a
little flow with it Wow and I like that
light is taking a little harder now yes
they need to fix them their heroic
strikes you know yeah you know then
we've got our graves they've got to fix
those rewards we know for the raid you
know what's called a raid but I feel
good man I feel like they are on the
right direction so and then this this
twelve I mean I mean I didn't I didn't
expect a development roadmap update with
more stuff I mean literally in two weeks
we getting you know the the crucible
testing ground thing getting exotic
armor stuff to play around and that's
the other thing like I'm having so much
fun playing with different exotics again
dusting off exotics seeing what all
these things are doing you know I mean
tractor caning right now is that
subtract your cannabis some guy was
kicking my bucket
I wanted to send the guy message because
he was using it perfect to he's just
like a Myrna Gordon Duke sweet it opened
me and I was just like my but I was like
I want to know because he was just like
woo crushing me with it and I was like I
wasn't even that's one of those like I'm
mad I'm just impressed it's just is this
rocking it so that thing works
sure I'm enjoying the grind too it's
like there's and it's like and you
have stuff to grind for it's not a gimme
I didn't just follow up and I will say
dude those exotic drop rates they have
lessened a lot to some extent extent I
have had I got another saints fourteen
helm that's fine I'm gonna definitely
have not seen as many right most places
so I'm glad they kind of tapered that
back so yes I agree I and their be
honest the exotic ground is real because
like I haven't gotten a lot of those
nodes ice the only thing I got I got
Soros back I haven't got throws I've got
that's like and I'm hearing people say
the same thing that you I haven't gotten
this I haven't gotten that I like that I
like that well benefactor and I actually
used the faded Engram because I wasn't
getting exotic so much lesser I actually
used it I did I did too I think mmm-hmm
yeah I the only other one I got is that
new warlock herb the sanguine dine out
sanguine outta me standing in a rift
grants and enhanced radar and marks
high-priority targets for you and your
allies here Lee people we're talking
about the whole seeing through walls
thinking people like oh crap so I got a
test that on my warlock for PvP yeah how
will you say I need that man I don't
even gotten that yet I mean eight looks
to it to like the detail on that thing
that's one of the best-looking warlock
herbs you can so I mean there's some
good stuff I mean sound design little
tweaks like you fire guns they sound
different were cliff coil sounds
different the just the enemies of music
when you boot it up war mine sounded so
good oh so good on that one so I mean
art sound music design function of guns
yes like we're getting better on
progression we're getting better on
rewards like there's their steps so all
these things are driving that ship
towards hopefully like home island to
come September when it's actually gonna
be the time we're like depart and we're
like this is the world we wanted a word
absolutely just one is respond someone
in chat real quick shop atlas one gaming
he's asking where the developers know in
that developers but
you have my suggestions he says um you
guys should make it where you they
should make it where you have put it in
the guns like attachments where you can
unlock and equip down on the gun like a
silenced or extended clip okay what
you're going for Atlas it sounds like
it's what we're hoping for with weapons
lot changes in September because that's
what we're we're wanting that
randomization that customization and
those extra perks that makes it a random
role that's what gives the chase that's
what gives that unique feel to the guns
so I see what you're going with it and I
think that's how they intend to probably
address it in September in that roadmap
so I would say stake tool for September
for that and thanks for subscribing that
was cool
though we would honored as always never
above thinking I mean yeah we're here
for you guys because you guys actually
enjoy listening to us we ramble and rant
rave and all that fun stuff so yeah I
mean I'm having fun I like if I run
around I'm like I don't mind just like
I'm gonna shoot like you know 200 more
people in the head with the Darcy that's
just got to happen at some point but
that's part that's and that is one of
those things that is better in d2
without a question like exotics the
masterworks the upgrade path on those I
like that lots of it now your path to
pick up exotics some of them are really
easy you know dropping from random
things make less of those have some
quests in there but the master work path
is great it's very very cool and it
gives you incentive like the game within
the game cuz you can you try to get
multiple things done at one time and I
love that man and its really I'm having
fun I have to admit it it's it's floored
it has its issues but you know like you
said the C++ with the arrow pointing up
yeah it's like it's like we see progress
come back to me in about three months
and let's see where you're at so and
this was like and I'm hoping come you
know September I would love to give
September an a absolutely would love to
so if this thing could come back what a
comeback with this be I mean there
probably if it came back eight I would
listen to our old flashlights but it was
just so we could here get engaged to
tell what you see I was the one saying
before it's like I don't know if they
can do as much
because I hadn't seen least monthly
updates the progress to feeling the
weapons like I hadn't had my hands on
anything yet it's like now's like it's
still some big changes but they had some
stuff in the works the new game mode has
me intrigued whatever they're doing with
the weapons there and a musician the
slots all of those are good there's one
thing I'm missing on that list on the
end and it's making Armour matter if
they can give me a reason for Armour to
matter stats perks like grenade throw
distance extra amo like put that stuff
back in there so I can build for a PE so
I have all the PvP or for all the sword
ammo I need if I'm gonna run around and
swipe people or you know I have you know
extra orbs falling from my helm in you
know enemies of the darkness like give
me the stuff back on my armor so it
matters so there's different stuff so it
cannot just say weapon randomization
because if armor doesn't matter it's
still half a game I know weapons are
what you fire but if I'm building a
character it's what I'm wearing for eh
now you talk of my life between saintly
I'm happy that's why I'm happy for that
what is it day at the 29th and then the
second part of it on July I'm happy by
July we'll know more about that that new
DLC in September and what they got
planned and hopefully that no more yeah
so that pretty much wrap it up guys I
know some of us are losing lack and
sleep here so a couple of us are gonna
pass out I've got a movie to go see this
afternoon so Deadpool 2 is in my future
looks like it should be crude but
hilarious so looking forward to all that
well yeah it's all you guys out there
you can always find me it's twitch
Twitter YouTube all those places it's
Eve on ttis all of them follow me
subscribe hit me with a comment shoot me
a message any questions if you guys ever
want to see anything answered in here
and we didn't get to it didn't catch and
chat just let us know I was like we're
happy to bring like if we ever get to a
point where we have a Q&A session I
would be a happy camper that means we
actually got people asking a stuff all
the time so that being said that's
pretty much where you can find me what
about you man lord Cognito here I mean
what podcast will return we're actually
gonna have a fun fun show it to me in
the inner circle Network let me tell you
we started our e3 prediction series man
it's gonna be lit it's good
Nintendo's up to bat he bonta's knows
because he was a panelist of last year's
Nintendo series so before we've got some
huge huge guess hopefully uh small wave
media press start Kofi um who else was
my boy potentially perfect and Nick
Tendo so it should be really cool and
shadows new new subs in in the chat
today shout that fear the beard saying
I'm him in the chat Atlas one game and
he's still talking I love him he's like
you guys play on Xbox one I play on Xbox
one
any boxes plays on PC on destiny just
for your record but on my gamertag is
Lord kognito all one word
check me out the clan is channel 5 all
the information should be in the
description if you can't find it but
more the Cognito you will be able to
find me on xbox but yeah man that's what
we got this Sunday check us out it's
gonna be fun we starting that prediction
series thing it's always fun type of
year and also tonight I'm on another
podcast it's gonna be all the planet
xbox in iron law podcast collabo podcast
and it's gonna be more xbox eccentric so
i'll check us out there kids move gaming
addict who you already know he does
double duty on to podcast it's gonna be
fun man so check us out an atlas one
game thank you so much thank you for the
compliments it's good seeing you in the
chat all right guys
yeah so to everybody out there I never
know where you guys are watching so
whether it's good morning good afternoon
- good evening hope you guys have a good
day thanks for tuning in and we'll see
what happens next let's see what
happened next week good next week is
gonna be touch and go everyone's
schedules all the way yeah so who knows
what next week will be but if not you
guys don't send us a message if we miss
next week might do a little solo video
or something if you're out or who knows
but we'll keep in touch with you guys
we'll be back as soon as we can
and we'll see you soon I guess these
days